yesterday I talked to you about this
just bizarre appearance by Donald Trump
at a hurricane relief event in Texas
where he did not talk about the now I
believe it's 30-plus fatalities at the
time it was 15 as a result of hurricane
Harvey didn't talk about the victims and
instead he just praised the size of the
crowd that turned up here is just a
reminder of that clip I played for you
yesterday that small mic really does
look huge in his hands it is interesting
how that happens so listen I said
yesterday if Trump praised the size of
the crowd and maybe also showed empathy
towards the victims of Hurricane Harvey
many of whom have been displaced some of
whom who have died this would be
slightly less disgusting but he didn't
he just talked about the crowds crowd
sighs it gets even worse we have also
now found out that Donald Trump went to
Texas did a briefing with the Texas
Republican governor Greg Abbott bragged
about the crowd sighs promoted his
personal line of hats his USA hat and
Melania Trump's FLOTUS hat but did not
meet with a single solitary victim of
hurricane Harvey shocking that mr.
empathy himself didn't meet with people
right it's really not unusual for
presidents to meet with the victims of a
disaster george w bush met with victims
of Hurricane Katrina in the Gulf Coast
after that event Barack Obama met with
victims after both superstorm sandy and
after the tornadoes in Joplin Missouri
this is starting to make me think that
Donald Trump might not actually care
despite seeming
desperate to be liked he's not taking
gimmies this is an easy one right you've
got thirty five percent approval rating
and you mess up a natural disaster
relief visit and you think that maybe
the new chief of staff John Kelly would
have realized hey one picture of Trump
hugging a hurricane victim like bush or
Obama dator Clinton would have been
eaten up by Trump's base it might have
bumped his approval rating up by a point
of two and they just didn't do it they
couldn't get it done I thought this
would be an aspect of the presidency
that Donald Trump might be good at
because you know the AI is billionaire
but you you think he's able to at least
reach out to people on the ground a
little bit more certainly you get that
impression from his rallies remember
Anthony scare Moochie said that the guy
is like one of us because he eats
cheeseburgers and pizza right but I
wonder if something has changed since
he's won the election and maybe he's
just a little bit more detached at this
point or well turning inward a little
bit more we've learned that he's very
very isolated because of the constant
scandal and just sits in the Oval Office
watching TV I don't know I was also
thinking about this from the victims
perspective right if I was a victim of a
flood in Texas or of a hurricane or a
tornado whatever the last person I'd
want to see is Donald Trump right and we
also have to consider from Trump's side
he is known for being a germaphobe touch
people who've been in contact with that
dirty floodwater I don't think so that
could be part of it as well but but
really what could Trump do for me in
terms of comfort and empathy I know he
doesn't care I wouldn't want to talk to
him either
he could sell you one of those hats
remember he was sporting the USA hat
that's now available on his website for
$40 and I haven't seen the FLOTUS hat
the Melania was wearing and are they
made in China if the victims of the
flood become vocal in their complaints
about Trump he won't hesitate to attack
the most ungrateful he'll slam them for
not evacuating even though there wasn't
an evacuation order I don't know they
start saying hey where are our checks
from FEMA next thing you know Trump will
be talking about those failing Texas
losers who keep asking for free stuff
sad or sick people expecting big crooked
government to pay for their stuff I
actually think Trump's the real victim
here because of the failing fake news
media it's fake very very fake folks
Trump is really the empathetic guy that
I don't know who claims that he is an
empathetic guy his kids I don't even
know I was I was gonna say that that his
advisers claimed him to be but very few
people actually even make the claim the
Trump is an empathetic no one seems to
know what's going on in his heart right
they'll tout his business credentials
everything else but they can't they
can't say what it's thinking right as a
general thing with this entire hurricane
relief effort it's really hard for me to
believe that on the turn of a dime the
United States can mount you know the
most advanced and well coordinated
military incursions anywhere in the
world right I mean overnight within 10
hours we arrive with the most modern
technology of every kind and we can't
prevent people from being stranded in
floodwaters for day after day after day
in our own state of Texas it some
element here convinces me that it's by
choice the response has not been better
war is very profitable I don't know if
hurricane cleanup is as profitable as
war is I think that's a big aspect to it
that probably is but it's just so
difficult to believe that this is the
best we could have done people desperate
to have you know CNN reporter ed
Lavandera help them i if you don't know
the story you can google it ed Lavandera
CNN reporter was literally doing flood
rescues in in in the Houston area when
reporting for CNN I mean it's just it's
all insane it's all completely insane
and you can continue talking to me about
it
on Twitter at D Pakman you can also
follow the show on Twitter for all the
latest clips and programming at David
Pakman show we'll take a break and be
back after this new sponsor today for
the David Pakman show today's episode
made possible by Blue Sky binary a forex
trading is a huge space millions of
traders around the world 80% of those
traders lose money in forex and usually
it's some combination of lacking the
appropriate knowledge may be relying on
others like traders or auto trading
platforms instead of themselves getting
emotional taking big risks maybe not
following proper money management rules
and blue sky binary offers their
education course and they are a leading
financial education and tech company
specifically focused on Forex they've
got senior traders with actual trading
experience and they offer a really well
structured and self-paced course in
forex to help with all of the above the
course includes video on-demand online
tests one-to-one sessions and access to
their community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and our viewers
and listeners can get a one week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David not
only does it include access to their
training platform but also you get a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics of forex trading afterwards
it is 9999 a month if you want to
continue you can stop and resume at any
point
check it out blue sky binary.com /d AV
ID